[Applause] If things
continue like this, the abduction won't happen, but he can
barely stand still. This is the deciding factor. The
next blow will
decide it. I'll ask you to write down the answer. Well then, I'm
kind of tired. Okay, next blow.
Decide with the next blow Decide with the next blow Decide
Next Next Next Next Next Next Decide Decide Decide Decide Decide
Well
done Next, Decide
Next,
Decide Next, Decide
[Music]
Adoja my sumi  I didn't
expect that attack to come at this timing, and the
jaws of evil
rose up in a daze. I looked up with my
eyes and shouted, "I'm sorry," as its
body accelerated from side to side.  The
deadly
Shiro, whose body is about 8 in size,
is Heaven's Road to Keio.It's my victory.
Can I do it for this much?